the Joe Rogan experience oh we took a
left but tie kiss I can it's it's like
700 horsepower I suit I think it's I
think they're calling it 610 horsepower
and 750 torque but just like the Tesla
the torque is instituted zero to zero so
you saw the video I sent you the [ __ ]
launch yeah it's you know you were
really splitting hairs here with the
Tesla in the Porsche of what you know
what it does to for feel different from
two five like not oh no my eyes hurt
yeah it's the same [ __ ] and the Porsche
has this really interesting thermal
management system so Tesla although they
do a beautiful road car for the city
you know they've never gone racing they
don't they don't know about endurance
racing or real real high performance
driving you mean you've seen them kind
of struggle with the Nurburgring a
little bit it's a little harder than it
looks over there what did happen with
the ring with the Tesla I think they
went over there with a prototype they
took the interior out of that product
yeah yeah - means the wide bot it's a
wide-body version with three engines I
believe yeah they wouldn't they weren't
talking about what it was but I think
it's a three motor car with a widened
body and a different aero package and
exercise there were some and they went
back with one with a giant liked gt3
wing on it - it seemed like they the
number they originally put out and you
guys talked about on the show Jamie
looked it up was a con um a compilation
of best sector times so they released
this sort of theoretical best time but
they never actually ran that complete
lap the big difference between a Tesla
and the Porsche right now is thermal
management managing heat and cool sort
of where it needs to go yeah there's the
prototype and I believe the Tesla can
build they're exactly the kind of
company that can build a one-off
prototype the Ghidorah the Nurburgring
very fast like they could do that you
could see how it's wider it looks cool
but the oh they didn't put out the apex
you show me a photo of the apex so Tesla
so the Taikan has this really
interesting thermal management system
that integrates the brakes the battery
the motors and the cabin he
he a cabin climate control all-in-one
system and so it's very common that one
system will need heat while the other
needs to be cooled and one will need so
they if the brakes are hot but then they
need to be cooled but the cabin is cold
and needs to be hot they use the brake
heat to they can send heat or cold
anywhere in the car it needs to go stay
up there
go back looks okay it's not that bad oh
it doesn't let you change it I've seen
one swap everything out with carbon
fiber but they put dope wheels on it but
the interiors were the management I
would like to see the interior I don't
really see a point to doing body kits on
TVs but yeah there's no quilted leather
little armrest some carbon I think the
idea is that I go go back up see the on
the left there with the body at the the
wheels are nice yeah they put larger
wheels why race what does that say on it
let's say unplugged on the brakes god I
think that's their company
oh oh it's called unplugged performance
yeah Apex unplugged
hey thanks s I mean it's not for me
think they put carbon-fiber brakes on it
how those carbon ceramic brake carbon
ceramic brakes I think a lot of money
for that I'm sure it's not I don't know
maybe the interior but I wouldn't carbon
ceramic brakes how about yeah maybe they
could do 19 so with Porsche like so
you're Tesla for instance if you want
max performance like the hardest launch
you can do right you got to have like
eighty percent battery or more and it'll
only let you do a couple of them in a
row before it starts to get noticeably
slower you know I mean it'll melt you
let you launch but you want that two
five or whatever it is it's only gonna
be your first couple launches where you
get it right the Tyco on will give you
full performance until the battery's
dead well so I get a full bore launch
controls start with like 40 miles of
range on the battery now how many miles
can it get from fully charged in theory
300 in theory yeah that's me driving
like an old lady so I was able to drive
around normally and I found that the
range estimate was pretty accurate I
look at the car for one day so it was
pretty accurate and then I went to the
canyons and in that video I burned off
40% of the battery just making that
video
really yeah it would be the same in a
Tesla it's not it's when you start
driving real fast and v's bro yeah you
you're just you're just smoking through
battery with the demand technology will
improve to the point where they can get
like real range out of these things like
the theoretical range of the Tesla
Roadster was like 600 miles but yeah and
that's never been done I think so I'm
not an expert on v's and there's like
electrical engineers it'll be screaming
[ __ ] with their iPods right now it's
I believe I know right I believe that
the 300 mile range is because that's a
good amount of range the key that we
will see that will really be a
game-changer his battery charge times
how can we get a charge in five minutes
or ten minutes and not thirty minutes or
an hour right and the number of stations
the opportunity to charge and that's an
issue with the Porsche over the Tesla's
they don't have the super charging
Network correct although they are using
the Electrify America network which is
actually it's another one of the
networks that stands for like normal EVs
it's actually bigger really but they
don't have as many super high speed
chargers so the Tesla and all EVs on the
market right now except the Taikan all
the rest are four hundred volt systems
okay and the Tesla's probably the best
most efficient use of four hundred volt
architecture eight hundred volt
architecture
if Porsche is to be believed is more
efficient the it's a lighter setup if it
flows in and out faster than the four
hundred volt system
there's a couple other advantages to it
but it can charge really really fast
through the correct chargers there just
aren't that many of the super fast ones
around there's only three in LA right
now one is in Burbank at the Best Buy in
Burbank is the closest one to here and
you I charge one from almost-dead to
almost full in about 18 minutes Wow that
one yeah but there just aren't very many
so so you can go stop grab a cup of
coffee
yeah that's by stroll around yeah you
come out you got 80% of your juice yeah
it was pretty good it went fast enough
that I could watch it go
seven really yeah yeah it was pretty
good like yeah if they get the number of
stations right I think the real problem
with Evy adoption especially in place of
La is an infrastructure man I don't
think this city generates enough
electricity through its grid for all of
us to be charging cars at home good
point right because it would if we got
all the millions of cars and they're now
charging it would radically change
everything yeah unless everybody
switches over to solar even much solar I
don't think is efficient enough France
the other problem is now it's a
homeowners thing and so like v's are
awesome like if you like how an Eevee
drives and you like the experience of
owning one and it works for your life
like a thousand percent get an Eevee but
is is a 90 percent Eevee adoption rate
in LA something that's really realistic
like not anytime soon dude what are we
talking about with cars there anything
else happening in the industry that you
want to know about well I mean the ty
can I don't think we've like completely
covered it no my question with all these
cars is what is next right it's like
right we're seeing these incredible zero
to sixty under three second times yeah
see we're going to eventually see the
range increase but if you had asked me
ten years ago are we gonna see a two
point four zero to sixty sedan that
feels like it's violating physics when
you stomp on the gas I mean that's what
I Drive a laptop for a screen yeah we've
got into a about I don't know right
right
maybe ten years ago or so the the the
trajectory of increased performance got
very steep yeah we're you know the new
version of every car has a hundred more
horsepower and now we've got these high
performance V's and with a high
performance evey you know you built a
dragster that that's a [ __ ] dragster I
mean the the the Tyco and does your does
a quarter-mile on the low tens I mean so
you can you know I don't want to be
flippant and say all it takes is money
but all it takes is money
you walk into a dealer and you buy in a
dragster that you know you you sit in an
arch NHRA licensed
run that fast now you could do it on the
way to Whole Foods that's great you know
and so with Taikan the real difference
for me between I get in Tesla is the
steering and handling because Tesla's
have very video Gabey steering it's
accurate and it's sharp but it's not I
don't feel it no this the Taikan has the
steering system from the Porsche 919 and
so it feels like a Porsche and so when I
drove it I texted you I go Joe
this is for you well Tesla figured out
how to make it go fast and they figured
out how to make it handle pretty good
make it cool they figure out how to make
it up and levy cool because v's remember
the rav4 eveything ed begley was driving
in the 90s like what is this Jaime video
the head on one of the things that makes
Porsche Taikan different is they have a
two speed transmission your Tesla is one
gear so your Tesla from zero to 120 is
bananas but it pretty much dies off
because it runs out of gear because most
people don't really need to go faster
than that but Porsche with their auto
bond stuff they need more at the top end
so the tie can actually switches into
second gear and keeps pulling like crazy
you know above 80 to 100 miles an hour
and the biggest difference though
dynamically is like you know how in your
Tesla you can drive with one foot like
one pedal we don't lift off the pedal it
breaks the car yeah and so you can
pretty much drive around one foot Taikan
doesn't do that so Porsche believes that
the kinetic energy built up by motion is
better used by allowing the car to just
coast as far as possible than by hitting
the region and capturing it in the form
of braking the way that Tesla does now
you concern that function off in the
Tesla does that have an impact on what
if it's doing that does it does it have
an impact on the way it feels well it
feels I mean yes because you have to use
the brakes more in every time a car
quicker to use the brakes more to do
mean to do have regenerative do we know
it doesn't necessarily slow the car down
faster meanwhile easy to zero time No
fact if I believe that Porsche is
ultimately better at that it's did that
the only real difference is that when
you lift off the gas and a Tesla it
slows down as if someone is applying the
brakes yeah in the Porsche you just pure
coast it's a pure Coast and it and it's
a really it's it's an even more of a
coast that feeling than a gasoline car
it's like you're freed of all restraint
like because after I'm [ __ ] mobbed up
the mountain in that video that I sent
you yeah I was like oh [ __ ] dude I've
only got like 40 miles of range left I
gotta get off this bloody Hill yeah and
so I was at the high point in the hill
and I go let's coast and so I just
coasted and I was like let's see how far
I can go without touching the brakes and
I got this [ __ ] coasting up to
like a hundred miles an hour taking
corners and not using the brakes cuz the
handling and the grip are so good i
coasted like 12 miles down the hill -
what about a deer what about a boy - oh
not that alertness [ __ ] while I'm
filming and I've never been able to not
stop the car no I believe me I know you
can drive but I saw the guys a little
log down the road just unfree on a chain
oh my god there was a guy in a Ford
Explorer driving in a windy Canyon like
this make a video this yeah I got caught
it on camera and with a log like the
size of like a car engine just free on a
chain swinging swinging yes take it
outside Jesus Christ
craziness sometimes I almost threw that
video in the garbage - it's amazing how
little of that they're really oh yeah
here it is right there back it up 20
seconds Jaime 20 more yeah so come
around this corner look long just free
dragging that [ __ ] is so crazy if he
thinks that so and if you back the video
up like 30 more seconds Jaime you can
actually see not in the very beginning a
little forward you can see see the trail
that the log has made on the road it's
it made like a like a line of kind of
dirt on the road and it goes back and
forth across the road and you go well
what the hell was that dude that's so
crazy you know what's really crazy about
that that could start a fire oh my god
probably but it could also swing into an
oncoming car that's like a five on
squeak into an oncoming car that guy
definitely doesn't have it's definitely
a terrible terrible idea but I managed
on a supercharged Lamborghini doing that
that's by the way that's not my YouTube
video someone has stolen my youtube
video [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] yo hit that fraud
protection Jamie that's incredible
that's a crazy thing to see yeah there's
knuckleheads out there man there's a lot
of them
[Applause]